Show. Okay. Ready? Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab and we're getting ready for, well,
this whole podcast you're about to hear is an invitation to join us in the next
podcast. We will be going
[inaudible] second year. This is not, I hate Facebook.
Hate that. Everybody knows that. So many of them,
ladies and gentlemen, I witnessed the death of privacy.
Yes. So that happened. We thought we'd throw it in anyhow, back to the flow.
So I'm glad I remember because Radiolab and this particular episode is more or
less an invitation for you to get ready for the next episode.
Yet today we have a preview of a,
an episode that we are working on furiously right now, uh,
about the periodic table of elements.
We're gonna tell individual stories about the different elements and those
stories are going to take us into outer space,
into deep manmade holes in the middle of America, into ourselves,
all kinds of places. So this week we decided to make a small telescoped, uh,
preview in which we go to one apartment in one building in the city of New York,
occupied by the rather singular Dr. Oliver sack.
We should say this was a visit we paid 10 about six, seven years ago I think.
And um, this is the story that in a very real way inspired us to do,
uh, this upcoming episode about the elements. And we also know by the way,
that Oliver isn't, isn't feeling so well right now,
which makes it particularly wonderful to hear him in enjoy.
Off we go.
I think there's always been a desire to somehow categorize and classify the
world around us.
I remember it and when you were in,
I don't know when it would be like an eighth grade when they,
when the teacher comes in in general science and he pulls down the periodic
table of elements wherever that, I mean,
that was one of the first times where I was like, yeah,
I don't want to be a scientist. It's not for me.
But for kids who love this kind of thing. Take Oliver Sacks for example.
Especially come in. Yeah,
so a couple of years ago we had went to talk to Oliver sacks about something.
Well,
it's actually mostly you that was going to talk to them and I was just tacking
along for the hell of it and for some reason we ended up in his bathroom.
I tend to read a little bit maybe to look at a book or something.
He seems to have facts and figures in his as well. There's a lot of us in there.
I'm sorry, sorry.
And that's when we noticed you're the periodic chart in the bathroom,
but he had a periodic table of the elements on the wall in the bathrooms.
We thought, wow, how funny. Periodic table in the bathroom. But then he said,
well, you know, if you go out into the couch,
you'll see type of cushion cushions embroidered with the periodic table.
Then he took us to his
bedroom. Although I don't usually take people into my bedroom. Oh,
we'll come where he showed us his periodic table, a comforter.
I tend to sleep here right under tungsten.
But the cool part was when he took us to the living room where you had this, uh,
describe what isn't before us here. And I'm like an altar. It's like a little,
a little dictionary Stan on top of,
which was a beautiful Mahogany box.
Say fine wooden box at the size of her back game and set core periodic table of
the elements is a very fine wooden buck if you care to open it.
All right? It's, it's,
it's a made of some sort of fine wood if it comes from Russia.
All right, man. Is there a trick to opening this? No.
[inaudible] okay.
We've all seen the periodic table being Alona chart,
but I don't want for his box. There were the chewable elements.
These are all these we have here like 90 some odd little, uh,
little tubes saw plus TV vials,
almost all the elements. Arsenic, bismuth,
[inaudible], manganese, mercury, nitrogenic, Lipton goal. Since I am,
for example, having my 77th birthday tomorrow. Yes.
And element 72 is half Niamh there isn't it for half a million little rocks
here. Here's what, here's what they sound like. If he's grabbing me,
I have coming to me. I hope it lives today and in got of half an im,
which will be very much more satisfying. What would you do with it in God?
But you can't do with the two little pebbles. I'll be able to hold as my hand.
I first love of chemistry had to do with the the said she wants. Yeah,
we one of the liquid elements. Hello me. I loved the colors.
Lousy Lee Brown fluidity luster. Pale golden can. Very, very beautiful.
The the physical property is a gas trapped in a little vial. Yes. I wasn't,
the one wouldn't want to drop that. Why not? I will, it's not good to with,
can I just jump in here for a second? Sure. Um, cause I, I really need to jump.
But the thing that's really crazy about that box and this you don't get from,
uh, from looking at a period periodic chart on a wall,
is that all those elements [inaudible] carbon nitrogen,
that's like to the world. I mean everything that we can see and perceive.
This table right here, the depth in my mouth, sky,
ocean, the mountains, it's all need of some combination. Yeah.
Bell Ms from that box and the box itself gives it all in deep,
deep order.
I had noticed myself,
I can't help noticing that the elements are organized in a very special sort of
way. For example, excuse me, I have managed to not notice.
I find it a little odd that you could organize them at all.
I don't even know how to begin the process of figuring out they're related in
some way. Well, we'll then, then you are sort of um, recapitulating what,
you know, what everyone felt in the, in the early days,
of course in the really early days people thought they were just four elements.
Ancient notion of elements took the form of earth,
fire and water.
Basically the thought that the whole world could be composed of these four
ingredients in different
ways. But then in the 18th century, we're skipping ahead a bit.
Chemists began to break things down into a smaller pieces like wind became gases
like oxygen and hydrogen and nitrogen and earth got divided up into things like
sulfur, phosphorus, iron,
and eventually chemists got all the way down to the root of it,
which was the atom. That's really what an element is.
It's a particular kind of Adam. The problem was though,
when chemists began to start measuring these atoms and they found that they were
all different sizes and types, like one would be heavy,
another would be light.
Third one would be really friendly Lex to link up with other Adams.
Where's the fourth would be a loner and they would come and combinations like a
heavy, friendly, heavy, shy, light, friendly, light shine.
What was the pattern? That was the question.
Could they fit all of these differences and similarities into one big
mentioned his name. You have to me here, show you a picture of the um, um,
here's where we get to Oliver's hero.
The Siberian big a mist I is called.
That would be Demitri Mandalay, the great men delay of who we will talk about.
Oliver has a black and white picture of him on his kitchen cabinets.
Man is not going to win any, any beauty contracts? No. He,
he jokes like a mixture between a Rasputin and um,
uh, who do, I mean, what do you mean? He is a big nose, a shaggy,
slightly unkempt white beard and mustache that goes all over the place.
Piercing eyes, thick eyebrows and looks like he's in a hunchback position.
Generally, if you met him on the sidewalk, you'd probably want to walk around.
Yeah. He didn't believe in wasting time. Gone to a Baba.
Let me just ask you as the degree of your passion, when you look at this man,
do you think he's a beautiful looking guy or do you see what I see? Um,
I think Mendeley,
I've had a beautiful mind and when that mind gets on a train and it was a long,
long ride from your coats to Moscow,
strange things will happen. As you're about to hear. We'll be right back.
My name's Annalise and I'm calling right before going to bed in Des Moines,
Iowa. Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology and the modern world.
More information about solution at www dot Sloan org
[inaudible]
hey everyone. It's me, Michelle Buteau.
I have a new podcast you can listen to right now.
It's called late night whenever from w NYC studios and it's like a late night
talk show before your ears. We've got it all honey monologues,
a live audience.
I'm musical bad kick in so many celebrity guests like Bridget Everett,
Leslie Odom, Jr Phoebe promise. Then you see where I'm going with this is good.
You don't want to miss it. That's late night. Whatever.
Subscribe where ever you get your podcast, but don't subscribe whenever.
Subscribe now.
Hey, I'm Jad up and rod.
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab and we're going to go back to Oliver sacks talking
about his hero. Did me treatment delay. Laugh now about to take a trip.
All right. Okay.
In 1860 alone and 1860 there were trains going all over Russia and Mendell f
could afford to take trains.
He was often on enormous journeys and to wile away the time since he couldn't do
chemical experiments or whatever,
he would take playing cards with the name of various elements that chemical and
physical properties and he would play what he called chemical solitaire,
sorting them for likeness or sorting. I'm afraid I,
I don't know the details,
but you know what we can imagine, right? Sure.
So let's just say he's Day sitting there on the train.
He's looking out the window. Your police sees trees made of Carbon
[inaudible],
a lake made of hydrogen and oxygen and oxygen behind that amount should you made
of silicone, any shuffling the properties,
are there atomic weights in his mind wondering how do these things go to Kevin?
What's the pattern? Any shuffling. I'm shuffling, shuffling,
shuffling range of lane of traffic.
And he did this for years until one night.
This we think is true.
In February of 1869 he is said to have had a dream industry.
All the atoms have all the elements of all the world.
If that wants a small noise, dense wants the heavy ones,
the friendly ones to shine. Once they all begin to dance in his mind and then
mapped into a grid,
the awoke with a vision of the periodic table,
Oh
oh dreams, which he then wrote on the back of an envelope.
[inaudible].
The thing about what he wrote on the back of that envelope is that it starts out
so simply left to right.
The Adam's just get heavier and heavier and heavier and heavier,
but every so often, and this is what he intuited in his dream,
is that while they're getting heavier there other traits like whether they're
shy or magnetic or whatever, those traits, oh,
repeat UDL declared change burger again and every time they do start a new
route, it properties repeating gain out of this simple repeating structure.
You get a table that you can read in a million ways.
There are so many ways to read this table.
I'm going to call this the PTO Dick Table that if you use your imagination,
okay,
you can see yourself in there.
I was a lot of a shy kid with a difficulty forming relationships.
Um,
and I sometimes compared myself to the inert gases in nerd cancers.
They're very isolated.
They react with nothing because I felt that they too had difficulties forming
relationships. But, um, I did, uh,
he goes now, left the chair and has moved to the library, is taking on a new,
a hugely thick, actually a dangerously thick book.
This is the handbook of physics and chemistry,
as you see it says 5,000 pages.
I had a smaller version as a boy,
and I'm from brooding in this book.
It seemed to me just possible that one of the inert gases is that norm might be
seduced into combination by the most active element of all,
which was flowing this lonely, lonely gas might find a partner somehow. Yeah.
Did they ever get together? In fact,
it came to me with great joy when I found out her in the 1960s that a actually a
Canadian chemistry, uh, had an effect, made a floodlight of xenon
elemental love. And speaking of love,
he then took us, he gets come here
to the living room and he showed us a small painting in the painting.
There was this dramatic figure of him
scowling character on the side of a mountain holding two stone tablets over his
head. And the sky was filled with lightning. And who was it? It was
Dimitri Mandalay. F when I heard of how Mindell AAF had, um,
discovered the periodic table.
I imagined men to laugh as a sort of Moses going up to a chemical Sinai and
coming down with a tablets of the periodic law.
And when I mentioned this fantasy to Peter Celkon, my friend, uh,
a, an artist or he did this imaginative picture of the young men,
Dilla f the peaks of a chemical Sinai behind him holding aloft the tablets of
the periodic table.
He's is maybe the deepest question of all,
did mentally think this up and impose it upon the world or was this pattern
always there? In which case mentally just removed
the veil and said, call very. You are,
is the periodic table a discovery or an intervention?
Is it a human construct or is it a revelation of the cost?
And before define water, is it so to speak? [inaudible]
[inaudible]
okay, so that was our visit with, wow.
Did I just get carried away with the sound? All right, so yes,
it is a little bit a closet cluttered, but this a long time ago.
It was a long time ago. Anyhow, that was our visits,
Oliver sacks and a also preview to an upcoming episode that we're making right
now about elements which we're really excited about.
I hope you'll be back for that. In the meantime, I'm Robert Krulwich.
I'm Jad AB and Ron, this is Radiolab. Thanks for listening.